you've probably seen this and it's wild
at 366 feet tall it's officially the
largest fear and the largest screen in
the world it's so massive that it took a
crane to assemble the Crane That Could
assemble the Dome the shell is a 580 000
square foot fully programmable LED
screen named the exosphere and believe
it or not the whole thing can run on a
single MacBook Air it's designed to give
you the most immersive experience with
an infrasound haptic flooring system
that carries base through the floors and
a beam form sound system embedded in the
walls that delivers sound directly to
each seat and I think it could
completely transform live entertainment
but at the price tag of 2.3 billion
dollars it's a big gamble so the MSG
sphere is it a pioneering breakthrough
or a massive waste of money
a portion of this video sponsored by
betterhelp I think there's something
about a sphere that's captivated the
human imagination for ages the ancient
Greek saw the sphere as an embodiment of
Harmony and Perfection boulay saw the
sphere as the sublime tribute to the
infinite Cosmos a symbol of the universe
Buckminster Fuller saw the sphere as the
epitome of efficiency and strength and
now we unveil the sphere the
perfect encapsulation of the 21st
century Zeitgeist what's unique about
the sphere is that the form and the
experience are one there are other
spherical venues around the world but
this is the first one to capitalize on
its form
and that's because the sphere is
actually one of the worst shapes for
Acoustics because the sound it bounces
around the hall and it gets muddled so
when you go inside spherical venues
there's still the traditional curved
boxes which is the ideal shape for
Acoustics so when they were building the
sphere they developed a new sound system
that uses audio beams to deliver sound
directly to individual scenes there's
000 speakers which means at roughly 20
000 seats there's about 8.4 speakers per
person essentially the whole Space is a
speaker this allows them to capitalize
on the spherical form to create a
completely new genre of entertainment
that's kind of a mix of a planetarium
IMAX Opera Hall and stadium and VR
goggles and it also includes haptic
technology for cooling winds rumbling
seats and even scents to people into the
show there's no columns or structural
obstructions and because your viewing
experience is not only towards the stage
but it's 360. every seat in the venue
will get a unique highly stimulating
experience well except these 800 seats
somebody's getting fired
U2 is going to be the opening act of the
sphere and there's a reason for that
according to Rolling Stone the band is a
natural fit for the sphere because
they're constantly experimenting and
trying to push the boundaries in live
music experience the problem is not
everyone is you too and actually there's
quite a lot of limitations on who can
perform there given the unique form
standard visuals are going to be very
distorted on the interior and the haptic
technology that adds another layer of
complexity there's a mini version of the
sphere that allows artists to test their
ideas before the show but even with that
the amount of effort and time required
is considerably higher than what they're
used to I mean what kind of camera can
even create videos for a gigantic 360
screen oh well there's one the MSG
Studio they developed a camera that's
the most capable of producing videos for
the interior screen so they kind of have
a monopoly on this even for you too they
said the time and expense is required to
develop the visual pieces it made it
really hard for them to be spontaneous
for their act this could turn off a lot
of artists because based on the time and
cost of developing a show for this venue
well first of all they'd have to sell
out the show and it might not be
practical to develop a whole show that
can only be played at this one venue a
lot of artists actually feel like the
flashy visuals would overpower the music
and when they were trying to secure the
act for the show a lot of artists just
straight up said no
[Music]
the exterior has a similar problem yes
it's going to be a whole new genre of
advertising that's creative and
different but right now there's not a
lot of companies who know how to Market
on a spherical screen which could be an
issue because it costs
2.3 billion dollars it could take them
um a long time to make that back and in
fact MSG and James Dolan the brainchild
and the primary investor behind the
sphere is currently facing lawsuits from
several construction companies for more
than three million dollars of unpaid
bills plus according to SMP Global the
sphere is going to take up about 95
000 megawatt hour of electricity
annually at the rate of 18 cents per
kilowatt hour in Vegas that's roughly
17.2 million dollars a year and just for
reference a typical commercial building
of between 15 000 to 25 000 square feet
consumes about 180 megawatt hour so the
sphere consumes the energy of roughly
529 of these buildings and with the
money they've already sunk into the
project and the money that they will be
paying the audience might be the ones
paying the price
I absolutely love what I do but it has
really Amplified this weird relationship
that I've always had with making
mistakes I'd always get into this Loop
of constantly overthinking and being
myself up for making the smallest
mistakes to a point where I was getting
exhausting and unproductive and it's
been really helpful to work with
therapists on recognizing some of my
thought patterns and just trying to make
some small improvements which is why I'm
really excited to tell you about today's
sponsor betterhelp makes therapy
accessible and affordable and it's a
hundred percent online so it's really
easy to adapt it to your schedule
finding a therapist can be really hard
especially if you're limited to the ones
in your area so if you're finding that
your therapist is not a good fit you can
easily switch to a new therapist for
free so if you follow the link
betterhelp.com damily you get 10 and off
your first month so you can try and see
if it helps thank you better Hull for
sponsoring this video so what I was
saying is they've already spent a lot of
money on this project but there are
those exceptional projects that despite
their costs or public pushbacks or the
amount of time it took to build have
been incredibly successful and they've
even become icons of their cities
they've transcended the mere function of
a building and they've become
destinations that people travel to and
this fear it could be one of those
buildings it's been shared millions of
times and it's kind of out of this world
and at its core it's a very Democratic
idea there's a connection between the
inside and the outside that allows the
indoor Ticket concert to be projected
outside for the non-paying audience to
scene this connection has never been
done before in a traditional music venue
because they typically require a very
controlled Lighting and Sound Edition
and so it is a first of its kind and it
has the opportunity to create some
really incredible public spaces or
viewing platforms but based on what
we're seeing right now any walking space
or public space around it is a little
underwhelming to the north we have this
massive Golf Club to the east we have a
bunch of Office Buildings and to itself
we have a Holiday Inn who will get these
fabulous views it's right along the
Vegas Monorail line so at least you can
see it while you're moving down the
strip right now it seems like most of
the sphere's exterior space will likely
be dedicated to parking to meet the
minimum of 13 900 spots and honestly
based on the skill of this thing I don't
even know what it's gonna be like to
stay up close but the renderings do show
a ring at the base so maybe that's in
the works if it does remain mostly
parking lots maybe it could at least
become a drive-in movie theater although
the sphere is a totally private project
and technically they don't have a lot of
responsibilities to improve the public
realm for a massive project like this
there's always opportunities to create
an amazing public sphere
take this
in Vegas alone there's tons of examples
of public viewing spaces that's created
by privately owned buildings but maybe
the best way we can compare will be to
look at the exact same building just in
a different context the MSG sphere in
Stratford and East London it's planned
on a 4.7 acre triangular site that's
been sitting empty for six years and the
key difference from Vegas is this Podium
surrounding the sphere and the variety
of public spaces that's programmed in
from the start there's the viewing space
there's the Serene Garden space there's
the community space and these different
levels create a very Dynamic public
space and there's not one not two but
four pedestrian access points that
connected to the surrounding Bridges so
that means you can come here and even if
you're not seeing a show you can come
and hang out and just watch whatever's
on the screen and they've actually
designed in a place for the audience to
gather outside
but despite how well it's been
integrated with the site 850 out of the
1200 resident groups voted against the
project who understandably said they
don't want to be forced to live face to
face with an enormous glowing
advertising ball the project is on a
temporary hole to address some of these
concerns but there are some big
Arguments for the project it's going to
create thousands of jobs and it's going
to bring in roughly 60
000 people daily for 300 days of the
year to this part of the city very sound
argument and so if this thing passes and
if they're able to figure out a way to
integrate this obnoxious object into an
urban environment that's gonna set a new
precedence for what's acceptable when it
comes to advertising disguised as
entertainment or for light pollution in
residential areas and as we have so
often seen we don't necessarily really
know the impact of these things until
it's a little too late
foreign
this was created using oils lights
colors and alcohol smashed between two
plates you place them on a projector
placed throughout the concert venue and
you sink the plates to the Beat of the
Music even this primitive technology saw
a mass adoption when it was developed in
the 60s and it transformed live
performances from a listening experience
to a visual experience look at how far
we've come we're entering yet another
era where music and art is a
multi-sensory experience that transcend
any other concert or Movie experience it
could open the doors to a completely new
expression of creativity
first Vegas now London this thing is
ripe for replication and as Trends
spread like wildfire these days we could
be seeing more and more of these giant
eyeballs all over the world but for all
its promise the sphere also poses some
fundamental concerns and it's especially
when things are so shiny and new that we
need to be extra diligent because things
that seem like progress sometimes have a
weird way of setting us back
[Music]
thanks for watching guys what do you
think about this fear let me know in the
comments I also have a Discord server
and a newsletter I'll leave the links
below and with that I'll see you guys in
the next video
[Music]